in the remote Amazonian village of in
Hebei the moan of the horns means a
grueling initiation is about to begin
several times a year the satyr a male
Indians hold a painful 11 hour ritual in
which boys as young as 12 must stick
their hands into a pair of specially
made gloves each one infested with a
swarm of angry stinging jungle
carnivores giant tropical bullet ants no
initiate can be considered a true Indian
a warrior until he has worn the gloves
not just once but 20 times this
afternoon Ted belt Rao will wear the ant
gloves for the first time with 19 more
to come busy people say that I don't
have the courage to do it I have and I
will do it the men face the prospect of
getting stung even before the ritual
starts when they head off to capture the
ants a stab from this predators
abdominal spear is 30 times worse than a
bee sting the tribes medicine man drugs
the ants by soaking them in an herbal
solution but their stupor will only last
long enough for them to be thrust one by
one stinger first into the gloves
according to the satyr a Maori legend
these menaces provide the perfect test
of one's worthiness to take on adult
roles
in less than an hour the ants are awake
trapped in the woven mint they ride an
angry desperation they're ready to be
inserted into the ceremonial gloves one
by one each young man steps up to the
sacred pole and submits his hands to the
swarm their agony is unmistakable to
help distract them the medicine man
leads them in a dance around the pole to
be seen as a true tribal warrior each
must endure the ants punishment for more
than 10 minutes with each sting the
bullet ants neurotoxic venom attacks the
nerves causing paralysis and terrible
pain and this is only the beginning
once the gloves are off the stinging and
burning will only grow more excruciating
now after watching the other suffer
heads moment of truth has arrived
unfazed he keeps dancing while all
around him the others to come to the
poison
slowly the neurotoxic venom is turning
their hands and just rollin simmering
paralyzed stumps finally the gloves come
off and Ted remain standing my body
feels like a motor that's heating up
if you feel water here a lot of smokers
come out it takes 24 hours for the
toxins to dissipate completely as the
chief sees it the ritual not only marks
the initiate entrance into adulthood it
makes them better men if you live your
life without suffering anything or
without any kind of effort it won't be
worth anything to you despite his long
hours of agony ted has promised the
chief he will wear the gloves 19 more
times until he becomes a true adult in
the eyes of the tribe